anywhere to what we saw on Monday we
just vote by a I think
[Music]
Steve and so the topic is let's say in
the first day we saw moles of single
Asian Dynamic models of that Indian
connections to strategies
settings
broadly in this topic they say the
approach will be very different across
talks sometimes that have more an
economic approach other thoughts yes
approach but that's why we are here to
combine The Best of Both Worlds so the
first speed that is I think within
assistant professor in
with the environmental competition if
you have
sure
yeah thanks for the introduction yeah
thanks for inviting me uh I'm gonna talk
about Markov persuasion process or MTP
and it's a reinforcement learning uh
this is based on two papers one is a
working paper with Matthew
and another is a recent UC Pepper with
my PhD students Chicago and this is Juan
John from Georgia Tech to a phone from
Google research one from Northwestern
tour and from Yo and Mike Jordan from UC
Berkeley
myself
um that's the outline for my talk today
so I'm going to start by introducing the
model of markup persuasion process or
MPP and then I'll talk about how to do
optimal planning MPP and then how to do
reinforcement learning I should start by
saying that this is a kind of pretty new
model that I'm very excited about but
there are a lot of open problems here so
I would be happy to discuss during the
talk or afterwards
um so what I'm what I'm going to show
you today is what we know so far but I
think there's a lot of interesting open
problems here
okay
um okay so I want to start with a kind
of a you know textbook style problem
that almost everyone here knows right
that's the Markov decision process this
is a very kind of famous planning
problem we have an agent you know uh the
agent is trying to interact with the
environment and try to make decisions so
typically you know this repeats at every
round that the agent is going to observe
some state from the environment and then
try to based on the state to take some
action to react on it and then the
environment transition to a different
state as Prime According to some
transition probability of transition
kernel and the meanwhile the agent
receives some reward that depends on the
states and also the action it's pretty
standard stuff uh but the important
thing to note here is that in this
problem we somehow assume the agent has
a dual rule the agent can both observe
the state of nature and also their act
right and what this target is about is
we're going to look at the case where
the state Observer is going to be a
different from the uh actor in this
problem uh in particular we have
Observer who will also be our planner in
this MPP model can observe the state of
the world but uh the another agent the
actor is going to act by taking actions
and but both agents gonna derive utility
from this process you know the planner
going to get some reward and agent the
actor gonna get some utility as well
but how do these two agents kind of
interact with each other and this is
where the idea of persuasion comes into
the picture uh in particular you can see
that the Observer have the information
Advantage right The Observer can observe
the state of the word but the actor may
only have some prior belief about the
state
and therefore the Observer can then
influence the actor's Behavior by
strategically communicating this
realized state to the actor
and this is what uh you know that has
been very extensive to study then you
can literature is called the persuasion
or information design
yes
okay so do the question is into the
planner and the actor came about
long-term or short-term so uh to yes so
the answer is you can choose whatever
model assumption you want in your
application but for this talk we're
going to assume that the planner cares
about the long-term utility but the
actor only care about their short-term
utility I'm going to tell you why I want
to focus on this in the in this talk but
but you don't have to do this depending
on your application the actor can be
long-term as well
okay any other questions
okay so you know why you know why we
care about this case you know why
sometimes the planner are going to be
different from the actor it turns out
that this actually happens a lot in many
applications for example if you think
about the right sharing platforms right
the the platform really has a lot of
information about the system uh for
example the supply and the demand and
stuff but you but usually but the system
cannot drive the system have to rely on
a lot of drivers to act and then derive
utility from this process and that's why
you see you know uh apps like uber it's
gonna partially reveal some kind of uh
search information to the driver with
the hope to kind of uh influence the
driver's behavior and this is already
happening around it
another example is a lot of kind of
digital market like bookings.com or
Amazon here you know these markets have
a lot of information about the the
online items like the hotel for sale uh
but its Revenue ultimately was generated
by the consumers who decided to purchase
or not and that is why you see those
kind of booking.com they actually reveal
information like you know there were
seven people booked in the past six
hours or two people booked in the past
one hour and so on and this kind of
information also affected the consumer's
purchase Behavior
uh another example is Google map right
Google Map knows a lot of traffic
information but ultimately the
congestion was decided by The Driver's
Choice the the you know the drivers for
is going to determine the congestion and
here you can see Google Map reveals
information to us in order to guide our
choice of the action
and you know many another kind of is
more real life example is a managers
typically know better about the state of
some projects but ultimately have to
rely on the underlyings to do the work
uh I guess some professors here maybe
also know what does this mean so after
becoming a faculty I I somehow feel more
and more that I'm doing the markup
persuasion process for this uh so you
know that's you know this kind of things
happen a lot in reality
um and therefore that's why you know in
this case we can look at how the planner
can influence the actor's decision of
your perspiration
the flannel also relies on the earth to
generate information
so that will not be important to the
model I'm going to talk about today
because the actor is going to be my
object so up the actor generates
information at their left of the system
foreign
[Music]
so you mentioned the agent is only cares
about current payoff right yeah is the
agent long list of meaning that
interacting artificial time so for the
application I talked about here I think
it's a national percentage of myopic
because imagine you're a driver right in
the right service system continue to
constitutive actions where somebody
interacted with so many different
factors therefore you can you don't
review the next interaction as a
freshman
demand in the system unless Uber tells
you
but if I'm a driver if I go to a
particular place that Uber says okay
there's a search price in this area
because it's very crowded I go there and
I see that oh no one is there oh yeah
good so here the important thing here is
the agent do not observe the state
before the text message after you take
the action it's okay to really preserve
this thing because nothing is going to
change it you already take the action
you leave this to leave the systems
right
yeah so the important thing is you don't
observe the state before you take the
action and that gives me the opportunity
to persuade you to take some action I
wanted
us applications
[Music]
such as the drought with Jerry that
knows the other one uh yeah that is a
good question so I somehow interested in
better the community
this is a software that's informatics so
after like a Year's operation or Uber
for example everyone knows what the
strategy is like whether their
recommendation is respiration
so that that is how I testified
okay so good yeah so hopefully this
Converses
there's a lot of situations where the
planner is going to be different from
the actors
we kind of to give you a concrete
example about how the planner can use
information to influence the actor's
Behavior so let me kind of jump use this
example of revealing the item popularity
in order to influence the consumers
purchase Behavior by the way this is uh
if this is a real problem it's already
happening in reality what I'm gonna do
next is basically just trying to
concretize this example with some kind
of math or some kind of simple math
actually
okay
um so you know for now for Simplicity
let's assume there's an online item that
have two states either it's high
popularity or low popularity
and as a consumer you know is interested
in this item you're gonna get utility
tool for purchasing the high item High
popularity or an active one for
purchasing a low uh low uh popularity
item you can choose to not purchase
anything and in this case you get
utility zero
a Priory the consumer believe that the
probability of high the probability that
the item is high popularity is one
quarter
okay now you know the consumer can make
a simple calculation to see whether he
wants to purchase the item he's going to
purchase the item if and only if when is
the expected utility for purchase which
is this simple calculation here is at
least a zero which is utility for not
purchase and this simple calculation
showed that this is the equivalent to
the probability of high popularity is at
least a one-third right just some simple
calculation but you know the consumers
now think that is the high high
popularity probability is only one
quarter so that's not enough to convince
him to buy the item
and on the other hand maybe the
booking.com you're going to get utility
too whenever there's a purchase in a
zero otherwise because you know
booking.com don't care about the item is
popular and I just care about whether
the purchase happens
but unfortunately without doing anything
uh you know the the consumer wouldn't be
convinced to buy that so the booking.com
I'm going to get utilities zero
fortunately the website has the
information advantage that is the you
know they really can't observe the
realize the state of high or low
popularity because they can really
monitor or the kind of browsing
activities for this particular hotel or
something
and therefore they can strategically
reveal signal this realize the state to
influence uh the consumer's purchase
Behavior that's exactly why you see in
the previous picture there was something
saying seven people purchased it in the
past five or four hours and that's the
information Revelation that's our
question yeah
same thing and with a myopic receiver
there is a one-to-one mapping between
the methods and the action so isn't it
like a classic mdp where instead of the
action being purchased or not the action
is what message you send
uh that's a great question yeah you're a
far uh uh Beyond but uh so did it
depends on how you model the belief of
the agent so if the believer of the
agent is Exodus doesn't depends on
anything happened before you can uh
somehow reduce this to a very
complicated mdp with complicated actions
but if the receiver at time age the
belief depends on the past the receivers
because you go to the website and you
saw those reviews and stuff then the
problem will become more difficult
because that's kind of the non-markov
impact in this market
okay so it turns out that there's a way
you know you can improve your uh the
chance of convincing the consumer to buy
that product so one simple way is you're
going to be honest with the consumer
that is whenever it's a high popularity
item you're going to tell the consumer
there's a high popularity for example
give it a star or maybe say some
sentence that this is in high demand
and whenever it's a low popularity you
can just stay silent uh that's you know
what happens in most website nowadays as
well and now from the consumer's
perspective if you see a kind of star or
recommendation you know that this item
is high popularity he should purchase it
and this happens with the probability
one quarter right so one quarter of the
time you can convince the consumer to
buy your product
uh is this the best way you can do uh
well the answer is no it turns out that
you can do it in a more strategic way to
significantly improve your utility and
here's what you can do whenever it's
high popularity of course you're going
to say this is you know High demanding
item but when is a low popularity two
out of the third of the time you're
gonna still say this is a high demanding
item otherwise you say you keep silent
you don't say anything
and now from the consumer's perspective
whenever he see a recommendation or Star
recommendation he know that this item is
not for sure High popularity but a
simple posterior update shows that it's
going to be high popularity with
probability one-thirds because you know
one-third comes from one third floor
comes from here two-thirds come from
here
and as as we see before this probability
one-third is large enough to convince
the consumer to buy the product
and this increase the probability of
purchase to three quarters
and this just gives you a kind of
concrete example to show how you can
leverage your informational advantage to
influence the actions of another actor
um and this is what we call it is the
signaling scheme
um it turns out that any questions so
far yes I'm ignoring my prayer
oh that's exactly you are not ignoring
because this one third comes from
exactly the priority because of the
prior you'll know that 0.5 goes from
here 0.25 goes come from yeah
okay good yes
yeah I was assuming the planner has to
be on the market for a few years right
so the customer knows what's wrong
because uh maybe if I'm looking to come
and this it just starts on things that
are not good then this will be a
reputation about between the government
yeah that's right that's why
so after you commit then you know you're
gonna follow this
whatever
most of the I.T industry because it's
not so easy to you know change your code
to to cheat for like half a day or two
days
foreign
optimal persuasion process actually so
and that I'm gonna mention this uh kind
of a geometric interpretation of what
this persuasion really means because
it's going to help me to uh to see how
we can generalize this to the sequential
setup so if we if we look at the problem
recall that there's a kind of a thresh
the consumers believe has a threshold
which is one-third uh between so if the
probability of high is more than
one-third the consumer gonna buy and the
booking.com reward is two otherwise the
booking.com reward is zero right and if
you record that originally the prior of
the consumer was here without doing
anything I cannot convince him to buy
but I had an optimal signaling scheme
that somehow achieved the utility here
which is three quarters times two times
two that was what I showed you before
and it turns out that this point lies
exactly between
these two points
okay and moreover I use the two signals
one is the star signal one is a silent
signal to achieve this utility and that
two signal corresponding exactly to this
point which is conditioning the the star
signal condition on which the
probability of high is one third and
then there's a silent signal or
conditional which is the probability the
high is zero but this is one third here
and therefore you can really view the
signal scheme I showed you before as it
convex decomposition of the prior here
into some probability of silence and
some probability of the star
and that's exactly how I achieved this
optimal signaling scheme uh optimal
utility here uh as this kind of a linear
combination and this turns out to not be
a coincidence uh because in a very uh in
a in a seminal paper by comenica and
Gensco they show that the sender's
reward under optimal persuasion actually
always lies at the concave closure of
the sender's utility function and in
this uh in this figure the concave
closure is exactly this blue figure here
that means you know if I move the prior
to here I know that at optimal affiliate
I'm going to get is here if I'm over
here the alternator is going to be here
this is kind of a very nice geometric
interpretation of optimal persuasion
that turns out to make it very
convenient to think about persuasion
good so okay so so far so good right so
we know how you can use the information
to influence agent Behavior but now you
might ask you know why I needed the
markup process right and the reason is
the following in the previous static
model and you can see that it cannot
capture how one consumer's shocking
Behavior may affect the future state of
life for example if one consumer
purchased item you could presumably
assume at for the next Consumer you're
going to say the book does eight times
in the past the six hour not to the
seven anymore
yeah right every consumer's behavior is
kind of changing the popularity instead
for the next Consumer and that's why we
needed this kind of a marketing uh State
uh some markovian transition for the
state to capture the evolved evolution
of the item state
so yes
so in many observations I I just feel
like here
the actual State isn't changing it's
just what we know about
right like I think of the stage in your
previous example it's the underlying
quality
of the right quality
right
um how much I know about whether it's
cool that's right it's like the history
of signature
yeah so that is so that is uh so the way
you are saying is uh correct that
there's a kind of equivalent way to view
it as the state is changing because uh
depending on how you define your state
this is the true underlined uh state
which is Milwaukee observe or it is the
fine grain information that you can
observe but the other people cannot
observe I think I'm in a later case but
what do you think in the formal case
that this turns out to be mathematically
some argument ah so okay so the answer
is yes
just like the belief for the posterior
belief on the right things in which case
then the consumers are controlling the
world
right the state is negative
uh I think I'm working on that if the
person if that if the consumer purchases
they all were not purchased and uh
uh planner have a better estimation
about the popularity right which is a
posterior update
okay so and graduated this adds to the
study of the Markov persuasion process
and the model is actually quite simple
very simple to think about you build on
top of a very standard Markov decision
process with step space s action space a
transition kernel and a reward function
and for this talk I'm going to assume
it's finite but again it's not necessary
you can do infinite Horizon as well
and the planner can only observe the
state so the planner is the only
Observer and after he observed the state
which the actor do not observe the
planner can you know execute some
signaling policy to reveal this
information to the actor and the actor
then you know take action based on the
information he receives and this then
leads to a state transition happens here
and both agents is going to get to their
own reward
uh as I said uh for this talk I'm going
to assume the receiver is my optic but
again you can look at the far side the
receiver uh but that's just beyond this
talk but but it's totally valid to
consider that
uh so and so here's a here are a few
quick notes on this model the first
thing is compared to Classic mdp planner
the planner in MPP has a limited
influence over the actions because in
MPP you can pick up whatever action you
want but here you have to really
incentivize the actor to take the action
and second the Assumption of the myopic
receiver is just my model in Choice uh
um and you know you can you don't have
to do this but I believe that is indeed
realistic in many applications that we
care about and there's also another
caveat is uh there are studies about
farsighted receiver in this marketing
process but it will show that is
actually very hard to optimize that
model uh this is do a very kind of a
nice work recently back again at all
which I think also got the outstanding
paper at the super AI 2020 uh
so that is hard yes
in Japanese
nothing
yeah yeah but that model has a very
special structure like how they said it
was transitions is a very special
condition called transition company
uh if I if I remember I think there is a
terminal state which is uh
also I believe the agent have binary
actions right
he is going to need something about that
paper is like
the amazing yourself
yeah we can't talk about that in later
outside but I think my impression is
that that model has a rich structure
that allows you to
analyze and do a reduction
version but the anti hardness count here
comes from it's a due to that the model
is the arbitrary it's already function
and after a state transitioning so that
makes the problem basically a markup
again with a very a kind of General
markup demo is two players both of them
care about the long-term utility and
that turns out to be hard to solve
computational in general
foreign
problem sometimes between mdp and the
general Markov games in the sense that
it's a more slightly more complicated
mdp in a sense there are another agents
who are affecting our decision but it's
also less complicated than the mark of
the general Markov games uh because the
receiver is near is myopic that allows
you to do a better optimization and that
I think is kind of a it's kind of a
sweet point in the sense it can capture
some voltage and problem but it's not
that that hard as the general Markov
game which is well known to be hard to
solve computationally
yes so to encode in the being your
setting I would set the reward function
of the
planner to be equal to very good
functions
yeah you need to change the actions as
well and your person needs to make it
the character to the long-term elections
so I have one action for each pair of
posterior and action thank you
so I think you don't need to change the
action because if you align the
incentive between the planner and the
actor then the planner will always
reveal for information because they have
exactly the same utility right
and that then the actors explaining
problems
because the planner the information
regulation is two years there they have
exactly the same utility right
yeah I can chat more often
what does the actor know they have to
know if
[Music]
everything is you know except that the
standard knows the state but the actor
do not know the state otherwise the
utilities are known the transitions are
just like a standard mdp right
everything is you know you just do the
optimal plane
but in the reinforcement learning
problem you can think about the
transitioning it's not to know or maybe
the reward function is not you know that
that's up to whether the problem
foreign
decision process but a very related
problem that I want to mention is the
incentivize the exploration which I
believe Alex is going to talk more in
this afternoon as well hey I want to
particularly mention this problem
because uh I.E and MPP actually
conceptually are trying to deal with the
the the the same question that is uh how
can we use information asymmetry to
influence the agent's Behavior so that
we can optimize the long-term utility
but these two problems actually
fundamentally different you have to list
the two aspects the first is that the
planner's information advantage in the
two Model come from two different
sources in the MPP problem the
information Advantage is that the
planner knows the realize the state but
the agents do not know but in the
incentivized exploration the information
Advantage comes from the planner knows
the historical data but the agents do
not know and that's not the case in
ppmtp even the receiver knows all the
historical data he still do not know the
realize the state and that's what the uh
that's what the only the planner knows
and the second key difference is the
utility structure are different so in
MPP will typically a laws that
arbitrarily misalign the utilities
between a planner and the receiver but
in incentivized Exploration so far
typically the work we're going to look
at the tension between the study the
tension between long-term utility for
the planner and the short-term utility
for the agent
uh yeah so confused about the the first
bullet so I thought the current state
comes from the posterioration they
Circle it is that's not if it's the
Bayesian view of learning
examples
that is right but I think there they use
the historical data which is realize the
trajectory in the past which help you to
update your estimation of the underlying
MTP
so
thanks I believe some more appropriate
that's the whole point is that you can I
see correctly things
[Music]
I guess another way to see the
difference it is
let's say the agent can observe or the
historical data right but Dana still
don't know what's gonna what is it to
realize the state at the current world
that's that's the Assumption in the mdp
model right just like the you know the
consumer do not know the current
popularity of the of the hotel and
that's something only the planner knows
but uh I guess in the incentivized
Explorer in this case the NPP still have
the information advantage but if you
know incentivize exploration into a
simulation knows all the historical data
then there's no information Advantage
from the assignment
could it be the case that's another
example that's closer to what you're
saying is inventory I am observing how
many items I have left which is like
perfectly observable by me I have seen
who has bought in the past the agents
Have Nots so I can track my inventory
transitions according to the previous
decisions and the game goes on the way
that you are describing it yeah that's
also
and yeah good we can we can chat more
uh okay so that is the model so
um for the rest of the time I think I'm
probably gonna go through this part uh
which I think uh we have some
characterization but a lot of open
problem as well so let's look at the
optimal planning MPP
um to Illustrated the idea of how do you
do optimal planning let's kind of
continue with the previous example I
showed you uh but now let's assume there
were a bunch of consumers you know there
were three consumers arrived
sequentially and they're they're all
interested in this hotel
and the popularity of the hotel are
going to evolve as the current consumer
gonna book it or not book it right
that's the state of nature going to
evolve
so how do I do optimal planning in this
problem and the idea is still similar to
mdp just to do backward induction but
you need to do it in a kind of a more
careful way so uh let's look at let's
start from the last consumer which is
consumer C and for you know let's assume
Let's uh for Simplicity let's say this C
was the the guy that I was talking about
before so his utility function can lead
to the booking.com's reward as this and
that's the picture you saw before and we
know that the optimal persuasion
basically is trying to concave this
curve to get the optimal utility from
this uh receiver C
so that that's already what we saw
before and the second step is now I want
to look at the receiver B right so I
need to do it in two steps the first
step is I'm going to compute the raw
reward function R2 to B for this
receiver B by the raw reward function I
mean I don't do persuasion I just try to
see how much utility I'm gonna get just
without any revealing any information so
therefore the receiver is going to
behave according to his prior belief key
and if P was a lot which is the
probability of high is large enough to
induce the booking then my utility gonna
be rb1 one it stands for booking and
zero sample not booking uh SP plus my
future reward which will be
transitioning according to the
transition kernel for action one and
multiply the current uh prior uh
prior belief key
that's gonna be the belief for the next
Consumer seat
uh if my probability is not enough to
induce is induced notebooking then I get
a different reward and the transition
happens according to a different kernel
as well
and that is how I computed the art tutor
but this is a raw reward function I
didn't do any persuasion yet so the next
step is I'm going to do persuasion that
is uh as I mentioned before this is to
can cavify this R to the function
to become the optimal utility under
persuasion so here's a really here's an
example for the two steps I start from
R2 to B and this is so I didn't show you
the numbers for this uh receiver B but I
did work out some numerical example
which turns out to have four pieces uh
for this R2 to be then I can do a
concurrification to get my RB
and I can continue this until the first
step and that's how you can do uh this
kind of development updates in this in
this model
and the only caveat here is that is the
number of pieces for this R2 to the B
function is going to increase
exponentially in the number of
iterations and that is why the problem
actually turns out to be hard in general
computationally hard uh to figure out
the optimal optimal policy
the question is actually a step three so
my suggestions
foreign
recursive formulation the first step is
basically for the receiver to make the
action the receiver are going to pick
you the best Edge according to his prior
belief key and this NH then will induce
a plenary currently which is uh the
current utility RH plus the future
off in the edge and then after that it's
the planner's optimization which can is
going to be a compatification of the
artery and even a recursive to do this
thing uh this generalizes the standard
efficient persuasion problem to multiple
Horizons and uh also in a standard MPP
right where you only have a single agent
making decisions you all have the first
decision the government is going to only
have the first system
the agent will optimize this for this
utility and not tested in my office so
that is the MTP but EMS MTP you will
have you will need two steps because
each step because because you have two
agents basically so each agent are gonna
need to make a decision during this uh
uh update
uh is this clear
okay so now so you know we have a
characterization of the optimal utility
but so as a computer scientist we
typically look at how can I compute the
optimal policy right uh but it turns out
that even though I have this
characterization the optimal the
optimization problem actually is quite
challenging uh this characterization
does not directly imply any efficient
algorithm because what I need to do is
to compute a discontinuous function RHP
High dimensional function for any Edge
from you know one to Capital H
and it turns out that this r h is a
piecewise linear function the last one
has a capital uh cardinality num a
pieces uh where a is a number of actions
and as you go forward the number of
cases is going to increase exponentially
uh in in the number of runs and that's
why you know I actually cannot have a
general algorithm to compute the optimum
policy
um and it turns out that there was some
kind of a special special cases where
you can have tractability
um one example is the following case I
was previously I was assuming the
receiver can only know the previous uh
signaling scheme and the signals but if
we assume the receiver can observe the
entire history particularly the previous
action and the state
then we can show that as optimal policy
in this case can be computed uh in
polynomial time
so why this simplifies the problem uh
the reason is because in this case we
don't need to compute the entire uh
reward function RH because there aren't
that many prior beliefs that I need to
keep track of
because for receiver at time H there are
only this many numbers of possible uh
history of the possible event at H minus
one and these are the things that are
going to affect my belief at time H and
there aren't that many possible beliefs
that that I need to handle in this case
it turns out that I can compute the
optimal policy for each of the believe
recursively in an efficient way
um answers are that you can really
generalize this to kind of uh uh to a
contextual setup by viewing the ah minus
one sh minus 1 as the context for the
receiver Edge at time H and in you you
know the context in general doesn't have
to be like this but it can be arbitual
context and you can generalize it to
that setup uh have a efficient algorithm
there and the idea is similar is really
because uh I don't need to compute the
entire reward function I only need to
compute the word function at a few uh
prior possible prior believe that can
happen
okay so I have um so in the so uh in the
remaining of the time I think I would
just briefly mention the challenges for
you to do reinforcement learning in this
problem and then I'll conclude
so you know the reinforcement learning
problem is very natural just as the you
know IO problem in standard mdp the
reason here is because uh you know
typically the transitions of the kernel
are typically unknown or maybe the
reward function are unknown and in this
case you want to play the game uh while
learning those transition kernels
and for um so I just want to mention a
few additional additional challenges
that doesn't present in a standard MVP
that would happen here so the first
thing is that you cannot easily explore
every action in MTP because the planner
has a limited power you cannot just say
I want to pick that action or that
action you have to incentivize the
receiver to take the action without the
perfect annoying your MVP and that turns
out to be challenging to handle and what
the way we do it is we can assume some
non-degeneracy assumption that is uh you
know the persuasion process would allow
me to explore every action that I want
maybe it takes a longer because I have a
limited power but ultimately I should be
able to explore every action so that is
going to be assumption that I will need
this is similar to the empty and if you
have a similar Assumption of kind of
exploring A reactions as well yes is
this an assumption on The Primitives or
is it an assumption on I'm hoping that
it will be equilibrium where I will be
using action I want to explore uh it's a
Samsung it's not a it's not a
equilibrium I just I just need to be
able to explore all the action in some
way not not necessarily equilibrium
about
another challenge is uh here the
smallest America area may lead to larger
laws because uh you know if you have a
small explanation error maybe for your
utility it doesn't change much but the
receiver may switch to a completely
different action which may be a disaster
and uh therefore because this is really
a due to the market Asian situation you
know sometimes my ability changes a
little bit but my my opponent may change
is uh uh switching his action which may
be a harm too so to handle this case we
essentially try to robustly induce some
kind of desire to receive an action so
we're going to make sure that within all
the uncertainties I will induce the same
receiver Behavior through pasta and
that's what we mean by the pessimism
part in our algorithm
uh the another the the final challenge
is the estimation error May propagate
through the time uh since the receiver
actually is believed no it depends on
what our estimation in the past
um and when estimating the value so more
specifically when estimating the value
of a given trajectory uh any estimation
error before H will affect the
estimation error of the receiver edges
believe and this doesn't happen in
standard uh ioemdp
uh when you fix a trajectory and it
turns out that in when arguing the
sample efficiency proof for the uh for
the uh for in the RL we will need to we
will need this step that we cannot
handle and that is why so this is
somehow a difficult problem that we
cannot handle so far what we can what we
can do is to assume that the receiver's
belief is somehow independent of the
history
uh so whatever happened in the past it
wouldn't affect the receiver I just
believe under this assumption it turns
out we can have a simple efficiency
algorithm uh for for Io in MPP and you
know this kind of is realistic in some
situation but did not in some other
situations
today
is that
happening
uh it's not I would say it's not
fundamentally different yeah the action
space in a bit differently right design
a signal on your skin and you need to
induce the desired receiver action in
order to make sure he doesn't negate
into action you don't like but other
than that I think that it's
fundamentally
is
okay so this is uh how far we can go so
far but I think there's a Long Way to
Grow
so by combining this with the the
standard optimism uh in uh the mdp
planning we get this optimism pessimism
principle for persuasion process that's
our algorithm uh due to time interest
I'm not going to show it in detail but
it's basically a kind of a very very
kind of simple procedure combines
optimism and pessimism and we can show
that at this algorithm going to have
square root of t n square root of H for
its regret
so there were some Pro techniques that
I'm I'm gonna skip I'll just stop here
by summarizing so we introduced the
novel model of micro persuasion process
applicable to many digital platforms but
we have uh some are we have algorithm
for the optimal planion area under some
kind of assumptions but I would say in
general there's a lot of open directions
um so for example how tight is our
result uh what about the algorithm for
General MPP how do we efficiently learn
when you don't assume the receivers
believe it is exogenous uh and there
were many other variants of the problem
as well for example what if the receiver
what if you don't know the receiver
utility Knight what if the receiver is a
far side as well what if there are
multiple receivers that is the same
wrong so all these questions are
so that's it for my talk thank you
questions